attention les cherry à mon top donc vous
mettrez comme ceci m'amène à soulever le
bras et j'ai même problème avec mon gygy
[Rires]
regarder quand on la voit comme ça si ce
relais des jo de pékin n'a vraiment
l'attention qui a passé le médecin se
dirige peut pas remplacer agathe c'est
trop lourd pour elle allez vas-y tu
rapaces agathe c'est trop lourd
alors c'est bon c'est mon attention
jamais vécu ça lui qui est très bien
pour la star iphone et maxi médias aussi
maxime est mieux c'est quoi ce terme et
d attention
quant à gaz c'est terminé pour agathe
alors il faut vous méfier là je vous
montrais la vague speech à bien respirer
comme ces mots vous avez perdu que
j'avais perdu mes deux bras s'est perdu
et perdu gagné s'est perdu et perdu
s'est perdue vous mettez le bas oui ben
bada son avenir s'est perdue alors que
ben castaldi j'entraîne paix et castaldi
ça va pas prétendu castaldi liftant tout
n'allait pas tendu géraldine se terminer
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
estelle le nez très très creux c'est
nord jean luc annaix
[Musique]
salut